so in addition to the cringe by the way
of the former US presidents and their
spouses ignoring Donald Trump at George
HW Bush's funeral I wanted to vote just
like a couple minutes
to trump sleeping at George HW Bush's
funeral when Trump plays golf all the
time it's not embarrassing but when he's
golfing he's not doing policy that's a
good thing because when he does policy
he wrecks the country maybe we should be
glad as we show you what this looked
like that Donald Trump was sleeping
during the funeral of George HW Bush
because when he's sleeping he's not
saying embarrassing things or doing
embarrassing things maybe that's the
upside to all of this but yes Donald
Trump appearing to sleep through the
funeral which is embarrassing but at
least he's not insulting anybody but
there is something serious here related
the trunk that I want to discuss that
sort of came to my mind in watching his
behavior and seeing how he was treated
at George HW Bush's funeral which is
that Trump was de facto rebuked at the
funeral as he should be his name wasn't
mentioned once by anybody period even
though he's the current President of the
United States we know Trump hates this
Trump wants recognition everything that
Trump said everything that was said
rather by george w bush during his
eulogy indicated that the Trump doctrine
the Trump milieu is the exact opposite
of what George HW Bush sort of worked to
build all of the compliments about
George HW Bush implicitly rebuked Trump
and Dana Millbank had a really good
explainer about this in the Washington
Post thousand points of light kept being
mentioned as as a catchphrase of George
HW Bush Trump made fun of it and at the
funeral it was mentioned time and again
as something positive that George HW
Bush had said George W Bush mentioned it
during his eulogy he also mentioned that
when George HW Bush won he shared credit
and when George
w Bush lost he took responsibility he
shouldered the blame that's the exact
opposite of Trump now I don't know if
Trump is clever or or intelligent enough
to realize that but these are de facto
rebukes of Donald Trump george w bush
talked about George HW Bush's
relationship with Bill Clinton and how
it was sort of a brotherhood that
developed that's not the way things are
developing for Donald Trump with former
presidents senator Alan Simpson spoke
former senator and pointed out that
George HW Bush never hated anyone that
is not something that can be said about
Donald Trump based on his behavior said
that he was loyal to the institutions of
government the exact opposite of what
we've seen from Donald Trump
now I concede that these de facto
rebukes of Trump are so over his head
Pat that I can't imagine Trump even
understands them as contrasting elements
of George HW Bush to him but to a lot of
the people in the audience it was very
clear yeah he may not he may not
understand them they may go over his
head but he does get annoyed I think
that he's not getting any recognition
from the speakers and essentially the
same thing happened when John McCain
passed away a few months back now Donald
Trump wasn't invited to that funeral
because McCain didn't want him there but
many of the speaker's had these sort of
tacit critiques of the current
administration and you can tell that it
hurts Trump I think especially so
because he actually had to sit through
it this time yeah he looked miserable
sitting there with his arms crossed and
just looking mr. when he wasn't sleeping
he looked very very clearly miserable
and one of the most subtle but brilliant
instances of trolling Trump that took
place during the eulogies yesterday at
George HW Bush's funeral was when the
former Canadian Prime Minister Brian
Mulroney spoke and pointed out that
world leaders knew that when they dealt
with George HW Bush they were dealing
with a gentleman they were dealing with
a distinguished and brave genuine leader
that's just about the furthest opposite
you can get
to George HW between George HW Bush and
how Donald Trump is seen by leaders
around the world and we see that Trump
is a child among adults just from how
he's being praised for how he behaved at
the funeral Chelsea Handler tweeted
about this brilliantly where she pointed
out Donald Trump is getting praised for
his behavior at Bush's funeral our
president is such an [ __ ] we have to
reward him when he doesn't make a scene
at a funeral which basically says it all
the standards have become so low the
expectation has become so low of Trump
that he was getting praised on cable
news the other day because he handled
the death of George HW Bush
appropriately that shouldn't even rate
when you evaluate how a president is
doing that they behave after a former
president dies now counts as a point in
favor of Trump because his behavior is
expected to be so atrocious and
ridiculous basically says it all one of
the days sponsors is privacy calm slash
Pakman which is a free service that I
myself use really useful in many
different ways takes just a few seconds
to link your debit card to privacy calm
then you can create virtual credit cards
that are linked directly to your bank
account and you use those virtual credit
card numbers to buy things online which
protects your actual debit card so that
it's not spread all over the internet
and one of the best things about it is
how their mobile app and browser
extensions for Chrome and Firefox make
it really easy to use let's say for
example that I'm signing up for a David
Pakman show membership in the credit
card number field I already see the
privacy comm icon I just click it choose
which of my virtual credit cards I want
to use and the credit card number
expiration date and security code are
automatically entered I can put in any
zip code I want and I'm done and if you
try to use my credit card number that
you just saw on the screen it doesn't
matter because I've already deleted that
virtual
card and that's the beauty of privacy
calm there are a ton of advantages to
using a free service like this for
example you can sign up for as many free
trials as you want then just delete the
virtual credit card you used and never
worry about getting charged for it it
protects you from getting hacked it
protects you when companies are hacked
which happens all the time
it is all completely free all you have
to do is click the link under this video
to get started and for a limited time
they're giving everyone in our audience
$5 towards your first purchase when you
sign up using that link